i spent more time on my hands and knees
picking through rugs um smoking anything
that
even remotely resembled crack cocaine
i probably smoked more parmesan cheese
than anyone
anyone that you know i'm sure tracy
wow that's exactly how i got fired from
pizza hut
[Applause]
yes
all right here we are again a brand new
show and a brand new greg
i'm as giddy as kamala harris explaining
kids in cages
or woody allen hearing about kids in
cages
if you've been watching the gg show on
saturdays welcome
if you love the five and felt the need
for more gg that's awesome
if you ended up here because you thought
your tv was the microwave oven
it's good to see you mr president
your pizza will be warm in two minutes
and hunter
he brought the extra cheese you all made
a great choice
for proof over at msnbc let's see what
brian williams
is up to right now evening i'm brian
williams
and i am on mars
yes i jumped on a chopper and now i'm on
mars
i've been here for a year now i built a
castle here
made of mastodon carcasses and
marshmallows
this is where i invented all the covid
vaccines
as well as penicillin the smartphone
and fluffernutter
some things never change meanwhile
what's on cnn
you sir are a racist
racist racist racist white
male racist racist
that's from the don lemon hour
who reports the news with the same look
your mother gave you when she found weed
in your sock drawer
as for those late night shows we're
supposed to compete against
why bother who do they offend the only
time stephen colbert ruffles feathers
is in a pillow fight the definition of
risk to kimmel
is dehydration from crying too much
fallon that guy fawns more than a herd
of deer
and i heard seth meyers and trevor noah
ran off to be obscure together
so let him be they got the market
cornered and calling americans stupid
to them it was never about trump it's
trump voters
it's not about guns but gun owners it's
not just about destroying statues it's
anyone who thinks math is real
it's not the issue it's the easy targets
meaning you
me i like bashing creeps in power those
stupid talking pinatas in politics
entertainment and especially the news
media because they're all the same
people
or in zuckerberg's case things that look
like people
and also because the only way they make
money is by making people hate each
other
it's not enough to say respectful
disagreement makes less money
you have to say it's racist that's why
to them twitter is a news
source it created cancel culture a
crowdsourced version of a hit piece
a gofundme page for character
assassination the press used to write
these hit pieces themselves
now they encourage steel cage matches so
they can sell ads and ratings
repurposing tweets into click bait
because it's profitable
cancel culture is to the media when an
atm in the lobby of a casino
is to an addicted gambler it's
democratized media destruction
putting a joker mask on reality
declaring everything
is not debatable but their power is an
illusion
their numbers are small it's just that
their constant noise
scares the hell out of corporations look
what's happening to delta
they're more scared of tweets than of
birds flying into their engines
which leads us to this could very well
be breaking news at least to us
i just found out about this today rob
manfred
the mlb commissioner said that the best
way to demonstrate our values as a sport
is by relocating this year's all-star
game and the draft
demonstrate our values as a sport
what's that mean in a sport where
stealing bases is a virtue
the sport that was racially segregated
for 70 years
where they pretended no players were on
steroids even as their ballooning heads
gave the goodyear blimp a complex
at least their heads swelled from growth
hormone not a sense of self-importance
clearly these cowards got spooked by
activists manipulating the media
because how is voter id immoral try
picking up nail polish remover in west
virginia without one
don't ask me how i know and remember the
all-star voting process allows
fans to vote five times over a 24-hour
period
that's ballot stuffing or in chicago
election day
mlb lecturing us on values is like me
lecturing you on
height meanwhile the president the
president calls the bill
jim crow on steroids yeah the so-called
great unifier
now flinging racial discord like
frisbees at a fish show
[Laughter]
so screw you mlb your stupid exhibition
game is about as entertaining
as a match of cornhole on espn at 3 00
a.m in the morning and screw delta and
screw coke
in fact screw all corporations you
stupid execs are cowards and bad golfers
you cheat on your taxes and you cheat on
each other i hope dems raised the
corporate tax to 99
except on fox which should be tax exempt
maybe i'm turning socialist but after
years of proclaiming corporations as
engines of free markets i realize their
locomotives
run by meth heads who'll do anything to
save their own hides
it's profit over people no matter how
many inclusion coordinators they hire
they'll turn a blind eye to china's
slave labor knowing that adding a
diversity fund run
to whatever history month currently
celebrated will stoke the woke in human
resources
it's not a principled stand it's their
way of doing business
it's no different than a bodega putting
up a blm sign
so maybe their store will survive the
demonstration
because they're scared well it's time to
return the favor
that's our job to scare the people who
delight in scaring you
sort of like an enforcer on a hockey
team but cuter
it's time to turn this one-way road into
a two-way street
think of it as part of biden's
infrastructure package except it's real
and it costs several trillion dollars
less